so i want to tell you guys about the  time i got to meet dixie demilia it was  pretty uneventful and i don't think she  remembers me but i'll tell you about it  anyway so i was allowed to tag along  to dixie's like i think photo shoot for  her merch at the time so you can see  there's like the car  and the photo shoot in the background  but this is me on top of the car  although i think it's i think this is  charlie demilio's car i'm not i'm not  sure but i think it is i got to meet  mark heidi dixie and charlie  and they actually are all so nice i  don't know why people like give them  hate on tick tock they're actually like  a really nice family but yeah that was  my  experience it's pretty uneventful i just  like watched them do the photo shoot and  then we left that was it